un nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix désormais
tous les soirs du lundi au vendredi à
20h10 avec vous à sereine verdien
bonsoir h rennes non sens marion
beaucoup de réactions aujourd'hui après
la conférence de presse fleuve
d'emmanuel mâcon qui a dévoilé hier son
programme oui sans surprise marion ses
adversaires se sont tous positionnés
contre ce projet certains dénoncent sa
violence d'autres crient au vol pur et
simple d'idées c'est le cas en
l'occurrence de valérie pécresse une
colère contre le chef de l'état aussi
alimenter ces jours-ci par l'hypothèse
qui circule d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée au lendemain du scrutin du
24 avril pour conforter la majorité
présidentielle une tactique qui serait
poussée par certains stratèges macro
nist c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirmait
cette semaine le canard enchaîné le
récap politique est signée florent
roudaut et nicolas ouvert
c'est l'histoire d'un coup de barre à
droite retraite à 65 ans contreparties
au rsa emmanuel macron en service après
vente à pau copie valérie pécresse qui
s'agace cerise sur le gâteau il n'exclut
pas de la nommer ministre s'il est réélu
et vice versa pas vraiment quoi
président de la république je ne le
prendrais pas comme ministre ministre de
l'intérieur avec 32% de hausse des
violences ministre de l'économie avec
mille milliards de dette où voulez-vous
qu'on le prenne
direct du droit pour la candidate et
l'air il percute du gauche pour un
hidalgo la socialiste en visite à la
grande mosquée de paris c'est donc en
même temps
faire payer toujours aux plus fragiles
aux catégories les plus modestes le coût
de toutes les crises en même temps
démanteler les grands services publics
si un modèle social français cher au
coeur de philippe boutin c'est le
trotskiste combat tout ce qu'incarne le
président candidat ma crainte c'est
vraiment la continuité des politiques
ultralibérales des politiques même
réactionnaire cette vieille idée de
droite stigmatise toujours la population
ont fait croire que finalement le
problème c'est en basse il ya des
chômeurs c'est parce qu'ils veulent pas
travailler avec sa campagne à minima
emmanuel macron tourner le dos aux
débats selon plusieurs rivaux sa
réélection que serait-elle illégitime
pour autant y at il un risque de voir le
scénario américain se répéter aucun si
l'on en croit marine le pen vous ne
serez pas le trump byden non je ne serai
pas le tram de biden non je n'ai jamais
remis en cause d'ailleurs les résultats
d'une élection de quelques manières que
ce soit et donc je ne le ferai pas c'est
pas de confrontation avant le premier
tour c'est le choix des manuels mâcon
qui doit se dire en même temps si ça
vole aussi barré dans ces petites moi
j'ai été condamné pour avoir dit la
vérité à non à ça ça s'appelle la
provocation willem cegedim social jeudi
au cassoulet la plupart des délinquants
sont arabes et noirs la france avait été
condamnée monsieur août la france l'om
aussi et vous aussi vous avez été
condamné pour atteinte aux intérêts
devant tout le monde le chérubin moi
aussi je vais avant tout la télévision
bras et peut-être vous serez condamné
mais violence sexiste vous serez
condamné
la plage objet de jolis merci c'est très
violent
dans les sondages c'est toujours lui
l'espoir de la gauche s'il se qualifie
pour le second tour jean luc mélenchon
pourra compter sur fabien roussel qui le
10 avril au soir de manuel macron et
jean luc mélenchon sont qualifiés pour
le second tour est ce que votre soutien
à jean-luc mélenchon est automatique oui
et je vous demanderai de poser la même
question à jean luc mélenchon et bien
sûr qu'ils disent que si je suis au
second tour qu'il appellera à voter pour
moi j'en avais doute pas voilà c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve
lundi
et ce vendredi la mémoire de la guerre
d'algérie a également ressurgi dans la
campagne car cette le 60e anniversaire
des accords d'evian qui ont mis fin
officiellement la guerre d'algérie oui
c'est justement le choix de cette date
qui pose problème aux yeux de deux
candidates celle des républicains tout
d'abord valérie pécresse qui a rappelé
que la grande majorité des victimes
civiles sont tombés après les accords
d'evian vous la voyez ici à nîmes auprès
de harkis même chose pour la candidate
du rassemblement national marine le pen
qui évoque elle aussi le sort de ces
dizaines de milliers de harkis
assassinés après cette date clin d'oeil
également aux rapatriés d'algérie les
fameux pieds-noirs 800 milles environ
avaient fui l'algérie après
l'indépendance du pays le 5 juillet 1962
on le sait le pouvoir d'achat et selon
les sondages la préoccupation numéro un
des français c'est encore plus le cas
depuis la guerre en ukraine oui première
préoccupation des français devant la
protection sociale la sécurité
l'immigration ou encore l'environnement
avant même la guerre la france
connaissait une inflation de 3 3 % les
prix de l'énergie étaient déjà en hausse
mais depuis l'invasion russe c'est la
flamber le prix de l'essence et du
diesel a dépassé la barre des 2 euros
avant de repasser juste en dessous de
cette barre en cette fin de semaine la
question est en tout cas au coeur de
cette campagne présidentielle on en
parle ce soir avec l'hymne rifaï
spécialiste économie sur france24
bonsoir line star wars tout d'abord les
différents candidats à la présidentielle
pour faire face à cette problématique du
pouvoir d'achat des français par cette
problématique du pouvoir d'achat elle
est notamment liée à la flambée des prix
de l'énergie et donc sans surprise la
plupart des candidats et bien ils ont
des propositions qui concerne les prix
de l'énergie ils veulent agir dessus et
en particulier agir sur la taxation du
carburant car vous le savez peut-être
60% du prix final que l'on paie à la
pompe est bien est constitué composé de
taxes alors il yad'abord marine le pen
qui propose depuis plusieurs mois déjà
de baisser la tva sur les carburants et
d'autres produits énergétiques en
faisant passer sa tva de 20% à 5 5% à
l'hidalgo pour le parti socialiste
propose aussi de le faire mais de
manière temporaire c'est le cas
également pour fabien roussel candidat
du parti communiste idée évoquée aussi
du côté de nicolas dupont aignan puis
une autre idée qui circule aussi pas
seulement baissé les taxes mais aussi
bloquer les prix à la pompe c'est par
exemple l'idée du candidat de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon qui
souhaite que l'on bloque les prix au
niveau d'avant crise autour de 1,4 euro
le litre donc de carburant alors que du
côté d'europe écologie les verts le
candidat donc yannick château propose
plutôt l'idée d'un chèque énergie autant
de 400 euros pour les ménages les plus
modestes et puis enfin pour si on
regarde à droite et bien valérie
pécresse appelle plutôt à ce que l'état
rende aux français aux consommateurs le
supplément d'impôt de taxes perçues
grâce à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
il dit que le gouvernement dit déjà
d'une certaine manière mettre en place à
partir du 1er avril puisque il y aura
une baisse de 15 centimes par litre
d'essence et ses candidats font aussi
des propositions pour augmenter les
salaires c'est vrai l'idée d'augmenter
les salaires elle fait elle est plutôt
donc proposés par la plupart des
candidats mais pas de la même manière
ils sont plutôt d'accord sur l'idée
qu'il faut augmenter les salaires pour
donner du pouvoir d'achat mais à gauche
c'est plutôt l'idée d'augmenter le smic
qui est proposée alors qu'à droite on y
va plutôt l'idée de baisser les charges
ou les cotisations alors si on regarde
la proposition qui concerne donc
l'augmentation du smic elle est là
plutôt parmi les candidats de gauche et
celle qui propose la plus forte
augmentation du smic c'est nathalie
arthaud donc qui propose un smic autour
de 2000 euros nets nathalie arthaud pour
lutte ouvrière et puis du côté donc 2 du
parti communiste ou encore du parti
europe ecologie les verts les candidats
proposent un smic à 1500 euros net alors
que jean luc mélenchon évoque l'idée
d'un smic à 1400 euros nets emmanuel
macron lui ne parle pas de hausse du
smic mais si on a entendu ces dernières
heures le gouvernement évoqué une hausse
du smic d'environ 25 euros nets à partir
de cet été il s'agit de la hausse
automatique liée à la revalorisation du
smic puisque l'inflation progresse
rapidement et puis il ya une autre idée
qui circule celle d'augmenter les
salaires nets pour tout le monde c'est
notamment le cas pour valérie pécresse
qui parle d'une hausse donc du ca des
salaires nets de 10% sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat comment ça une mesure
financée notamment par des baisses de
cotisations notamment les cotisations
vieillesse et puis cette idée elle
circule aussi chez eric zemmour donc pas
les 10% mais l'idée de baisser les
cotisations sur les salaires pour
augmenter le salaire net et cela devrait
selon lui permettre une augmentation du
smic de près de 100 euros net merci
beaucoup ligne pour cet éclairage donc
sur la problématique du pouvoir d'achat
est je le rappelle on vous retrouve
chaque vendredi dans eco de campagne
c'est maintenant l'heure de notre
portrait du jour le premier d'une série
de douze consacrés aux candidats à la
présidentielle oui à 23 jours du premier
tour elle n'est crédité que de deux et
demi pour cent des intentions de vote
selon un sondage ipsos sopra steria
publié aujourd'hui on est très loin de
la dynamique qui avait porté au pouvoir
les socialistes françois hollande sans
même parler de françois mitterrand il
n'empêche la candidate socialiste anne
hidalgo croient toujours dur comme fer
en sa destinée et ne compte pas jeter l
éponge son portrait signé in est sous la
garde
première femme élue maire de paris anne
hidalgo est bien décidé à faire son
chemin jusqu'à l'elysée et d'après son
entourage la candidate anti voiture
c'est bien contourner les obstacles qui
se mettent en travers de sa route comme
ce jour de 2014 en pleine campagne
municipale elle est rentrée un soir tard
comme tous les soirs de la campagne son
mari était en déplacement dans une
capitale européenne et elle avait perdu
ses clefs et
le lendemain il m'a raconté que
plutôt des pertes du temps un plein sur
israël a escaladé la façade 20 son
balcon pour pouvoir rentrer par gisèle
par une porte fenêtre on est en pleine
campagne ce qui n'est quand même pas
très raisonnable ce qu'on a failli se
retrouver sans candidate avant
d'escalader des balcons parisien anne
hidalgo a connu d'autres péripéties né
dans le sud de l'espagne en 1959 celle
qui s'appelle alors encore anne a grandi
dans une famille ouvrière alors qu'elle
n'a que deux ans séparant fui le régime
de franco et viennent s'installer en
france la jeune fille obtient ensuite la
nationalité française à 14 ans en 1997
anne hidalgo est inspectrice du travail
elle intègre le ministère de l'emploi et
c'est sa rencontre avec martine aubry
qui l'a fait basculer dans le monde de
la politique à l'heure de la
présidentielle l'actuel maire de lille
continue de lui apporter son soutien on
a besoin d'un homme pour porter ce
qu'attendent les français des réponses à
leurs problèmes pour elle seule la
fraternité et la laïcité permettront une
société rassembler et réconcilier et on
en a vraiment besoin
en 2000 ans anne hidalgo fait son entrée
à la mairie de paris en tant que
première adjointe de bertrand delanoë
et elle n'en partira plus treize ans
plus tard elle finit par remplacer son
mentor élus face à sa rivale de droite
nathalie kosciusko morizet c'est la
victoire des valeurs républicaines
c'est la victoire de l'authenticité
c'est la victoire d'une gauche fidèle à
son idéal paris
paris anne hidalgo dirige depuis
maintenant huit ans et qui lui colle à
la peau pour de nombreux électeurs cette
image de parisienne avaient été ré est
un frein pour accéder à l'elysée mais la
candidate à la présidentielle voit
plutôt la capitale comme un tremplin
celui qui lui a permis de se faire
connaître au delà du périphérique en
décrochant les jeux olympiques de 2024
djo qu'anne hidalgo espère bien
accueillir depuis la tribune
présidentielle
[Musique]
et on termine avec notre archive bonus
du jour oui un écho au thème du pouvoir
d'achat centrale on l'a vu dans cette
campagne une archive de nicolas sarkozy
du 8 janvier 2008 soit huit mois après
son arrivée au pouvoir il est déjà loin
le volontarisme affiché durant sa
campagne désormais le président de la
république ne cache pas son impuissance
face à la hausse des prix lui qui se
présentait pourtant comme le président
du pouvoir d'achat écouter
alors s'agissant d'ailleurs du pouvoir
d'achat qu'est ce que vous attendez
moins que je vide des caisses qui sont
déjà vides où je donne des ordres à des
entreprises qui j'ai pas de données a
donné l'ordre si c'est ça votre
conception de politiques mais on se
trompe on parle pas de la même chose
réduire le débat politique français à la
seule question du pouvoir d'achat staps
urd voilà c'est tout pour ce soir marion
temps merci h rennes lors du choix c'est
à retrouver aussi sur notre site
internet france 24 points comme et sur
les réseaux sociaux on vous retrouve
lundi à la même heure à lundi rester
avec nos centres dans quelques minutes
pour un nouveau journal